previously on startup I started a
company called not vine which is a
platform to share 6.1 second looping
videos I have a rich nemesis called REO
who embarrassed me in a game of chess I
started to work on not fine and then
suddenly Aria launched refined before us
allowing people to share 5.9 second
videos the agility on the active users
we have so far
[Music]
53,000 that's crazy when we have 35,000
last week yeah we're actually growing
really fast we just surpassed a rebound
a few days ago there's surround 45 say
wow that's amazing and I gotta go now
keep up the good work all right oh great
going yeah we're gonna say you want to
eat I'm not sure why but I think it's
about refine but I'm gonna go see
someone else beforehand so who are you
going to see the tech need
[Music]
[Applause]
are you the tech lead is the sky blue is
the earth flat is react native in the
future hmm I see wait one who I am
doesn't matter it is where you are that
matters you are everywhere but yet lost
so you are nowhere in your mind but yet
you stand here in the flesh the Tecla is
everywhere it is all around us even now
in this very backyard that my parents
let me stay in while I cash in on my
unemployment checks
I am the tech lead and I am
you detect me
[Music]
how'd you read minds active users please
no actually how'd you get done well I
made an extension that makes it easy for
people to cut six second clips from
YouTube and upload them to either rerun
or not button it has a pixel that logs
all their internet activity so that way
I can track revives use your base for
your size so you're logging every single
website they visit yeah everyone all
right then what's the most popular
website that I visit porn so what are
you doing Joey told me to move the
videos by 10 pixels word on the street
is that you're a tech lead at Google is
that true they said you were a legend
it's a good question but someone
inefficiently asked the time complexity
of your question is linear to the number
of words you are using can you do any
better
perhaps sublinear logarithmic before we
get to the answer let's try
whiteboarding the question you have 30
minutes please speak aloud while you're
thinking as you're working okay so are
you the technique oogle
well I quit several months ago
[Music]
yeah I really wish this place had chain
you know supposed to be someone like me
who works out daily so as your superhot
girlfriend can't teach me how to code
and defeat Aria yes but only if you
defeat me in a one-on-one duel to the
death okay but like not not to the death
right okay fine
[Music]
you have the power to win the battle
without coding when you start using your
heart you won't need IDE s or terminals
you must tap into the elemental power
you were born with what language should
I learn first how many language should I
know what framework should I use do you
use vim or Emacs code alone will not
solve your problems I've written all
kinds of code in my life but the
strongest code is inside you
finally I push my feet check man
my mother works lots of us feel
overworked just standard for Silicon
Valley yeah suck it up and deal with
it's not only hearing the other
promotion promotion genius do you think
some me will control me what's the last
thing you even did I just push the 11000
line feature you literally changed all
the spaces two tabs you're right it was
more than just 11000 lines I deserve
more recognition
I should people my soda it's killer be
killed out there John whenever I want a
promotion I walk up to the CTO with
eight offers in hand I tell them their
site won't last a week without me I
couldn't begin for me to stay I'm a
secret Tiger urine tiger okay I think I
know you're trying to say in order for
me to get that promotion
I need to look smarter
Hey I want to talk do you smell kappas
no um anyway um so I wanted to talk to
you about what is it John I'm busy
trying to revert your eleven thousand
line feature oh well I think I deserve I
mean I have an offer from Microsoft yeah
I'm running out of coffee can you go out
and grab me some just keep the change
like a bonus
[Music]
you didn't need this here drink this
wait is this piss why'd you do that I'll
make you another one
hey guys this job is gone we can do
whatever we want or we can all hook up
with each other
come on let's meditate
I gotta be more assertive
suddenly I'm reviewing your code and I
see something unsightly yeah sure what's
up you see here can you tell me what
you're doing here I'm catching errors
see so here's the thing at nine we don't
catch errors we want less errors
[Music]
hey guys so today's my last day working
here at not mine it's been so great
working with you all and this is such an
amazing team and you guys are so lucky
to have each other but you know I think
it's time for me to move on where are
you going my love I got married in
Canada keep this with you
[Music]
we're gonna miss you make sure you stay
hydrated with hint water you can get 10%
off if you go to pinko slash Jomo that's
Jo MA you'll always be part of the team
you're not buying family now and your
friends can be not buying family too if
they go to Jonas why calm then get shirt
for as cheap is only $25
[Music]
all right guys hey man this is useless
this is not working man this is a waste
of my time I knew it meant you're old
you know nothing about this world you
don't even work at Google anymore I'm
trying to free your mind Joma but I can
only show you the door
you're the one that has to walk through
it I should have known this was a scam I
once stood in your place and I too was
disrespectful my I offer you some advice
forget everything you think you know
[Music]
hey everyone if you like this video
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe thank you alright
thank you for watching it was amazing it
was really fun shooting star of Episode
seven so if you enjoyed it as much as we
do don't forget to Like subscribe and
today is Genovese last day yeah but you
want to say anything to our fans thank
you for having me and I had such a good
time yeah she's always like that I'm
sorry for not being in the last episode
I just wasn't around but this one so I
hope you'll enjoy this video
but anyways peace out